[Music]
the mystery may be over for a handful of
car owners but the questions remain for
the company behind an enigmatic new car
last night Tesla began delivering its
model 3 electric car it's Tesla's most
affordable vehicle and CEO Elon Musk is
making a risky bet that the model 3
could make electric cars mainstream John
Blackstone was at Tesla's of California
factory as the first cars were delivered
with fanfare fit for a rockstar decimal
launched its model 3 CEO Elon Musk's
ambition is making this the electric car
with a mass-market we're gonna do
everything we possibly can to give you
the car as soon as possible right now
the model 3 is pretty much everything to
Tesla this is the car that they have to
get right to ensure that their business
continues the model 3 costs around
$35,000 with an all-electric range of
more than 200 miles
Tesla's previous models started nearly
$70,000 has there ever been a car
salesman like Elon Musk Elon Musk is is
I think is beyond a car salesman I mean
he's more like a you know a hero for a
lot of folks and I think the the
opportunity to buy a car from his
company and be a part of his movement is
attractive to a lot of people so
attractive that since the model 3 was
unveiled in March last year more than
400,000 people have put down $1,000 each
to get on the waiting list to buy one to
satisfy all those orders musk says Tesla
will build 500,000 cars a year by the
end of 2018 but in all of 2016 Tesla
built fewer than 90,000 cars some of the
production targets are pretty ambitious
you know people have doubted Tesla
before but the fact that they are you
know rolling cars off that people are
going to drive you know says a lot those
are actual owners getting actual
production cars electric cars may be
quiet but Tesla continues to generate
plenty of buzz
CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone in San Francisco yeah